should we go on to the second one my
second one shows that parent time in the
animation
time the animation i want can you guess
what it's about
okay i i i know exactly why i've seen
this before as well yeah i haven't seen
this in a
very very long time but i'm a huge fan
of uh
i forgot the guy who made it but like
tosh i'm a fan of tosh's stuff so like
i love the dojin of this and i'm like
yeah thank god they kept the art style
because like that's
that's my number one thing so the
premise was this guy wakes up
and he needs to find an heir yeah
because he's like a king or a ball or a
billionaire
yeah so he needs to make an air which is
like typical hentai plot 101 yeah you
need to make an air here are
a bunch of females you you can possibly
make an air with and there's like two
hot ones
there's two okay ones and there's a
[ __ ] lolli and it's like for [ __ ]
sake
and it's cool and then so they all just
start [ __ ] and it's like okay yeah
all right fine
all right no it's it's a no [ __ ] one
yeah it's like straight but like
okay it was like like i was saying
earlier like when is when is a harem too
much
because for me anything after three is
just like
that that's when i think it's too much
you know two is a nice choice
three is pushing it four it's a time
management problem
you know like like some days right i'm
not gonna lie i
i struggle to like you know even take
care of myself what makes you think i
would take care of five [ __ ] women on
top
that's because you're trying to look at
this in a realistic aspect i
yeah it's well that's the thing don't
look at it as if that's me
just look at it like there's a dude
who's okay i'm not a [ __ ] joey
i wanted to be me i i don't care i don't
even care about realism what i care
about is material because when you have
a harem
you can only have like so much screen
time for one girl right and we've all
read the [ __ ] harum de jinches
where it's like you you're [ __ ] like
five to seven girls
and every girl gets one one page one
page
how can i be satisfied with just one
page for a girl hi i'm beyond her girl
with big tits
hi i'm small hell girl with small tips
yeah and i think they fit like three
different positions on like one page
and i'm just like this is just speed
running sex now like
like this this like there's no [ __ ]
foreplay there's no anything you're just
getting straight into it again
i like to be spoiled for choice all
right like sometimes you know
that's the thing though it's like it's
like i can always go back to harem time
and be like all right well maybe if i
just want to focus on one goal then i
would i will focus on too much it was
you give me like give me like five girls
give me like one episode
it needs to be one episode per girl and
then maybe one haram episode at the end
which i don't give a [ __ ] about
cause it's all about the one episode per
girl that's that's that's
that's fair that's fair that that is my
structure i need structure in my hentai
and that is the struggle
when you're watching a harem right the
one thing i [ __ ] hate is like you
know
when you know i'm enjoying a scene with
a particular girl and then it cuts the
[ __ ] lolly
and i'm like well there goes it there
goes yeah what else to do now it's all
over
like because because it's not one
episode you're constantly like having to
[ __ ] be like all right this seems
good go go go go it's go time
you know because you don't nut actually
on the lolly because you you're probably
like [ __ ]
fbi is knocking on the door just
just imagine that it's a milf no what
the [ __ ]
just imagine that it's like a small
table you're honest your honor i
imagined that it was a milk
i plead the the stick which is imagining
that it's a milf
okay i just imagine you watching like
this harem
harem time and you just like [ __ ]
timestamp and timestamp everything
it's just like okay you download the
episode
1528 uh lolly scene skip okay
uh 1720 not here
on the milf looking character okay i put
minus
100 points for having a lolli oh my god
well so why was the side plot better
than the main plot
what do you mean what the [ __ ] was that
what was this with the mom and the
sister
no no no no no like they just oh yeah
yeah yeah with the one where he it was
the girl that he fell in love with the
school yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah who
eventually joins the harem right yeah
yeah yeah
that that was better than that yeah
you got some character development there
you got a natural relationship and then
she joins the harem and i'm just like
it's ruined ruins yeah yeah and then
she's like oh i don't know and then
she's like i hate it right when the
girl's like oh no i don't know and then
the moment they start [ __ ] they start
doing like
triple suplex [ __ ] positions and it's
like what are you what are you what the
[ __ ]
jk i've heard the kamasutra yeah she
starts like [ __ ]
throwing him over his head like what
what the [ __ ] is happening i just love
when she was like ooh
i don't know and the other girls were
just like haha let's see about that you
just start stripping her
let's just start like ramming her into
them and it's like whoa
no but like i'm i'm guessing you pick
this one i mean have you seen the
did you were you like more of a fan of
the source material or were you more of
a fan of the actual adams
[ __ ] love harem i i do i do like
harry potter like i like i i saw these
two shows i'm like
is joey a harem guy i like my hands man
like look i've always even with like the
the non like like non-hand-tied like
dojin like manga and stuff like that
like anything
she feels like adhd porn like i can't i
can't [ __ ] focus i'm like what am i
what's going on
i like to be spoiled for trouble it's
not about being small for choice it's
about having like
a sufficient amount of time to get
invested in one girl and
enjoy if i wanted to invest in one girl
i would read a romance story
no no that's what that's for no no yes
come off it
no no i don't i don't read the harem to
be like
yes i'm gonna care about this one girl
and one girl only because that
completely goes against harams
if i want to care about one girl if i
wanted to pick all right it's like all
right
i want to go i want this girl to get
with the main guy and have this like
beautiful romantic relationship all this
character development
i'd read a romance manga that's what
that's what that's for
a harem is not you're not supposed to
read a harem to [ __ ] get invested in
one game i disagree
even in [ __ ] harry manga they pick a
girl
and there's a reason there's a reason we
fight over the best girl not it's
because the best girl
we only want one girl not all harems
though have a best girl also i'm not
gonna like
for me do you think that harem is like
kind of spoiled when they're all just in
on it and like happy with the situation
yeah
i like it when they're like i like it
when they're fighting
this yeah and you know there needs to be
some [ __ ] spice if everyone's like
happy
yeah it's [ __ ] yeah come on the best
part is like half the danger man that's
why school days was semi good at times
it's like yo you gotta get his chick
dick chopped off and
i don't know well i like to play with i
like to play games in easy mode
like but vanilla harems is just like
that's two easy modes
but that's why i don't read vanilla
harems i need some spice in there that's
like saying yeah i'm a gamer and go play
cookie clicker it's like what are you
doing this is like the easiest [ __ ]
mode
right i hate it joey it was it was
boring and it wasted my time
i mean look at least i can say there's
better animated than [ __ ] mother
knows breasts
i will that is a masterpiece of
storytelling
i was i i
i do want to mention torch again though
because it it i feel like i feel like
that's the reason you picked this yeah
because tosh is like
this legendary dojinshi artist who went
on to make
uh shokugeki you know soma
so like i remember watching this and i
remember i've never seen haram time
because they [ __ ] look like
sometimes yeah yeah that's the reason
why because he's the same artist
and i remember because i've never
watched this actual anime before but the
dope
like the dojin is [ __ ] godzilla yeah
and like i [ __ ] hate harem
harem dojins but like his art carries
this so much
and it was like it was really weird
watching this adaptation because it was
it just reminded me why i want high
quality
anti-adaptations because like yeah i'm
not gonna lie the animation
wasn't that great yeah right i mean it's
pretty did you okay did you also
like like all the girls because when i
turn a hentai on
immediately i'm like these two girls are
the ones i like or one of the girls like
i immediately single out
i mean yeah i definitely have like
favorites that's for sure but like i
i don't know i don't really like to
watch or read harems where if i if
there's like a single girl i just
cannot [ __ ] stand right yeah like
that's the reason why like i didn't like
infinite straddles for example because
there was that one girl who i just
couldn't
[ __ ] stand and that just completely
ruined all the other goals for me
whereas like with heroin like i don't
know i don't think that deeply when it
comes to hentai though it's just like
i'm not gonna
i'm not going to sit at like a bunch of
like [ __ ] girls in a hentai harem and
be like
yes i don't like the personality of this
one girl therefore completely ruined
like
that's not what i watched that's not
what i read tosh for like i read tosh
because
these girls are hot these like his his
art is god tier
like so you look for like the art and
the animation more than like the premise
or i
i look at both i look for both i
definitely think that that's why it's so
hard for me to find my perfect hand side
because it's so
[ __ ] hard to find both and like what
i would say is
watching this kind of reminded me why i
think i'm going to make like a blanket
statement where
i don't think there's a hentai
adaptation that is better than the
source material i agree with that and
there's there's a reason for this
although i haven't read [ __ ]
none of us have read mother notice come
on is there even
when i busted a nut to that that was one
of those ones where you're like oh [ __ ]
you look at you like jesus christ this
is like post not regrets christ post not
regrets
jesus christ i'm going in the bookmarks
but [ __ ] connor you're disgusting yeah
yeah this is it's the ones where you
like
you've been trying to pick the perfect
show for like ages and you're like
i guess i guess it'll be this one today
then my mind tell me
no i've spent i've spent [ __ ] half an
hour trying to pick the perfect
one to not see i guess it's one order
yeah this this will have to do yeah but
no because like
there are plenty of like [ __ ] amazing
dojinshi artists
where they like like someone like tosh
who is so good that he is now just a
straight up just a manga artist
but the problem with hentai adaptations
is that
no matter how good the source material
is because as we as we've established
source material can be good
if not better like than actual manga
yeah but the problem is
no matter how good the source material
is the adaptation and the animation will
always be
subpar mediocre right it's like if every
anime adaptation
was just like done by jc staff second
team there is no ufotable or bones of
hentai
you just like even like pink pineapple
like some of the best that they can do
is still like b to c tier well pink
pineapple is just
pineapple is just the a1 but you're
obviously getting 10 yeah yeah yeah
you're obviously going to lose some of
the detail when you do it in animation
right yeah
it can't be one for one yeah but like i
said i would i would gladly
like drop 50 of the quality if it means
it's moving like
i am [ __ ] sick and i don't want to
[ __ ] physically but that's because
you can't get off the dog
i don't want to why the [ __ ] would i
want to physically turn a page
read anything but because because okay
okay i'm going to continue this
conversation when we get to
your next pick um because when i expect
my last ones
my last one i think i know it's it's
your queen beeping should we just skip
to you
whenever is that my second on my third
i'm pretty sure no
you you picked okay so here here's our
new connor had [ __ ] taste
he picked one milky studio adaptation
and
two queen bee adam are they both two yes
both of them were queens
why the [ __ ] do they get all the good
stories it's pissing me off that's the
[ __ ] problem yeah that's why they are
the milky of this generation
i have i can totally be like i'm so [ __ ]
i hate you so much but god
damn you you're good yeah and pink
pineapple's the opposite right like
there's a great animation but that's
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah is that like for some
reason some dude who has all the good
plots they have like a [ __ ] round
table somewhere in tokyo
and they like decide the best plot like
some nba draft and they give it to the
worst [ __ ] studios
and which one would you like to see the
queen bee and this is like i'll take
these